code again for five months from now
let's make it permanent
the house and the biden administration
should support this effort lives are at
stake
it's important that we continue to focus
this body as we have
on the demand side of this equation
prevention
term recovery for fentanyl and for other
substances
but it's also important that we not
allow these substances
to come on the streets at lower and
lower costs and greater and greater
volumes
that is what would happen if we do not
move as a congress to ensure
that these fentanyl copycats and
fentanyl itself remains
illicit drugs as they are let's do the
right thing for our communities the
right thing for law enforcement let's be
sure they have the predictability and
certainty in law enforcement
to know that these criminals can be
prosecuted these traffickers
we need to act now to address the threat
of these deadly fentanyl drugs
coming into our communities i urge the
senate to pass the fight fentanyl bill
join us in this effort so we can better
work to reverse the tragic rise
in overdose stress around the united
states of america i yield the floor
um
so
[Music]
[Music]
senator from ohio
thank you mr president the vote we're
about to take
on this event holland resolution sj
res 15 is a bipartisan opportunity for
us to show
people that people whom we serve that
were on their side
states all over the country red and blue
states states in the south
in midwest on both coasts have all
recognized
that people need protections from
predatory lenders
that's why nearly every state in the
district of columbia
have passed laws to limit to cap
the interest the amount of interest that
can be charged
on payday and other loans in the late
1990s
payday lenders desperate to find a way
to evade state law
that limited them from charging
exorbitant interest rates
that trap people in a cycle of debt they
can't get out of
no matter how or how hard they work they
came up with what
the control of the currency called rent
a charter
what we now know is a rent-a-bank scheme
because banks are generally not subject
to these state laws
payday lenders funneled their loans
through a small number of
of willing banks it looked like the
banks were making the loans
when it was really the payday lenders
federal regulators
both parties republicans and democrats
through this
very obvious route that hurt low-income
people
that were forced to get credit any way
they could
federal regulators crack down under both
president bush
and president obama the office
controller of the currency the federal
department
corporation occ and fdic shut down a
series of these schemes
by payday lenders and banks states from
across the country
also stepped in to protect their
residents georgia
west virginia my state of ohio
pennsylvania new york maryland montana
south dakota colorado illinois
virginia nebraska all pass
new laws and regulations either stop
these schemes
or to cap interest rates and payday
loans at 36
still a very very high number that most
of us never pay
but people that can only get credit that
way end up paying it unfortunately
still a high number that obviously will
make any company making these loans
plenty of money several other states
including california and ohio
also pass laws to limit the interest
that can be charged on consumer loans
these new laws pass with overwhelming
bipartisan
support now get this more than 75
percent of voters in nebraska and south
dakota
supported the ballot issues initiatives
to cap interest rates
on payday loans so three-fourths of the
voters going to the polls
in a popular vote wanted to cap interest
rates and payday loans
in those two states in recent years new
financial technology companies emerged
that partner with banks to offer
responsible small dollar loans
at more affordable rates
but we also have a separate group of
online payday lenders
resurrecting the same old rent-a-bank
scheme
to offer abusive high interest loans
they're not even attempting to hide it
mr president
one online lender told its investors it
would get around
california's new law by making loans
through this these were
these were their words this lender banks
making loans through bank sponsors not
subject to the same proposed
state level rate limitations so it's
even now he or she
is even acknowledging that states voters
or state legislatures or both are saying
we want to cap those interests to
interest rates so people don't take out
a
small loan and end up paying 200
300 time to 200 300 after
after these these payday lenders uh did
after these payday lenders was i put
put that on that another lender said
there's no reason why we wouldn't be
able to replace
our california business with a bank
program
so they know what they have to do they
know they're they're they're going
against the intent
of the legislature and the intent of the
voters given the
broad bipartisan support for these laws
we had hoped that the trump occ
would take action and crack down on
these schemes the same way that
bush and obama had done schemes that
have been rejected by voters and
legislatures
over and over in state after state after
state but last year
the occ issued what's known as the true
lender rule
overruling voters of both parties giving
essentially a free pass
to these abusive rent-a-bank schemes
now to fight back on behalf of
low-income people on behalf of
fair play a broad bipartisan coalition
is asking congress
to overturn the occ's harmful true
lender rule
that support includes credit unions
state bank regulators
republicans and democrats alike state
attorneys general of both parties
one of the most outspoken has been the
republican attorney general of nebraska
because his state passed his state's
voters passed
past the limit 75 percent of them to
keep interest rates down
support from small business groups
support from the military officers
association of america we know that
payday lenders
especially prey on young members of the
military
one of them may be off in a foreign
country while the
spouse stays back at the base or stays
back in a community
particularly in in is struggling with
with with
just having the resources to get by
they're preyed upon so often
another group the national association
of evangelicals
the southern baptist convention other
members of the faith
and just lending coalition that
coalition wrote to congress
quote predatory payday and auto title
lenders
are notorious for exploiting loopholes
in order to offer debt trap loans to
families struggling to make ends meet
the occ's true lender rule creates a
loophole big enough
to drive a truck through that came from
this coalition coalition
again attorneys general military
officers association national
association of evangelicals
southern baptist convention they're
saying the occ's
true lender rule creates a loophole big
enough to drive a truck through
we know why these common sense laws that
our states passed are popular we know
why they enjoy bipartisan support in
states across the country
people don't want abusive lenders to
prey on them
their loved ones their neighbors some
issues that come
before the senate are complicated they
divide people there are thorny nuances
to consider
mr president this isn't one of them it's
simple
let the people let's protect the people
whom we serve
they've clearly cried out for us to do
this
we should protect those people i urge my
colleagues to support
sg sj res 15 to overturn this rule
i yield the floor
[Music]
do
uh
uh mr president first let me thank our
chair of the banking committee
uh and somebody who has fought against
the abuses in the financial services
industry throughout his career
uh senator brown let me also thank
senator van holland
who again has been one of those leaders
and doing great things
uh to help people who are often taken
advantage of
now for millions of working americans mr
president
one of the most dangerous things that
can happen is falling victim to
predatory lenders
unscrupulous actors have always promised
quick quick
cash or credit to people with unexpected
expenses or
financial difficulties only to trap them
with crippling interest rates
that can erase a person's life savings
or even claim their homes
they're in trouble they reach out for
the lifeline and the lifeline's a trap
often they're trapped for years and even
some for their whole lives
and that's why more than 40 states have
passed laws that prohibit this behavior
and place limits on interest rates made
by non-ranking lenders
runs the gamut from liberal california
to conservative texas
inexplicably inexplicably
the trump administration decided to give
these predatory lenders a massive
loophole to circumvent state law and
once again prey on low-income americans
under the trump's administration's rule
so long as payday lenders found a bank
to provide the cash upfront and attach
their name to the transaction
interest rates in the triple digits were
suddenly okay even if the state
explicitly banned it
is despicable it was so typical of the
trump administration not caring
about average folks at all and just
just uh listening to the special
interests
it had devastating consequences for
working families
and for small businesses in new york
the owner of a southern food restaurant
in harlem
took out a sixty seven thousand dollar
loan from a fraudulent lender to make
renovations to their restaurant
they fell behind on payments and tried
to work with their lender
when coveted hit and realized that their
loan had an apr of 268
percent rather than work towards a
solution
the lender went to the bank to try and
foreclose on their property
their property in which they had put
blood and sweat and tears
saying the trump rule gave him the
grounds to do so
it mattered little that new york state
law
had a 268 percent interest rate as
blatantly
illegal so today's vote is simple
it would revoke the trump
administration's so-called true lender
rule that permits predatory lenders to
exploit small businesses and working
americans
in the middle of a pandemic the last
thing we should be doing is perpetrating
a rule that makes it easier for payday
lenders to scam working people and
business owners
with today's vote the senate stands up
for working families and small
businesses all across the country
by repealing this terrible essentially
scrooge-like rule pushed by former
president trump and his allies and one
final point
for those out there who say elections
don't make a difference just look at
this
here was a rule protecting people states
protected people
the trump administration comes in and
rips away those protections
leaving so many people bare and
defenseless
because they're desperate they need the
money
elections occur a new democratic
president
a democratic senate and this horrible
horrible rule changed by the trump
administration
is undone we go back to giving some help
and protection to working families and
small business people this story could
be repeated not just with cras but up
and down the line
up and down the line elections do make a
difference
and today's vote shows one of many
examples
i yield the floor and as for the
consensus
the clerk will read the title of the
joint resolution for the third time
calendar number 57 sj res 15
joint resolution providing for
congressional disapproval under chapter
8 of title 5
united states code and so forth
the question is on passage of the joint
resolution
i asked for the a's is there a
sufficient second
there appears to be the clerk will call
the roll
miss baldwin mr barrasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr bozeman mr braun mr brown
mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy ms collins
mr coons mr cornyn
ms cortez masto
mr cotton mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr danes
ms duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
this is feinstein
mrs fisher
mr joe lebron mrs gillibrand
mr graham
[Music]
mr graham mr grassley mr hagerty
miss hassan mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
ms klobuchar
mr lankford
[Music]
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
ms lummus
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
ms murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr rish
mr romney
ms rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
[Music]
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
ms smith
ms stabenow
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tubberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
ms warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr yang
[Music]
so
blue
so
so
foreign
senators voting in the affirmative
bennett
brown cardin casey
brown cardin casey
duckworth feinstein marky
murray schumer smith and white house
senators voting in the negative mr
schatz mr
schatz eye senators voting in the
negative
blackburn burr capital
grassley holly inhofe
toomey and tuberville
mr reed mr reed i
mr young mr young no
mr johnson mr johnson no
mr padilla mr padilla aye mr carper mr
carper
aye mrs fisher mrs fisher
no mr kane mr kane i
mr wicker mr wicker no
mr tester mr tester i
foreign
uh
mr wyden mr wyden i
mr sass mr sass no mr scott mr scott of
florida
no
[Music]
mr durbin mr durbin aye
mr lee mr lee no
mr boseman mr boseman no
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal aye
mr danes mr danes no
mr rish mr rish no
miss lumis miss lummus i
miss baldwin miss baldwin i
mr mansion mr mansion i
mr crapo mr crapo no
mr marshall mr marshall no
mr peters mr peters i miss hassan
miss hassan aye ms cortez masto ms
cortez masto
i'm mrs shaheen mrs shaheen aye mrs
gillibrand mrs gillibrand
i'm ms hirono ms hirono i'm mr kelly mr
kelly
aye
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith no
[Music]
so mr paul
mr paul no mr cassidy mr cassidy
no
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper i
mr barrasso mr barrasso no
mr warner mr warner aye
shoot
ms cantwell miss cantwell i
[Music]
mr moran mr moran no
mr rounds mr rounds no
mr van hollen mr van hollen i
[Music]
mr murphy mr murphy
ms rosen ms rosen aye
mr kramer mr cramer
[Music]
no
mr portman mr portman no
mr hagerty mr hagerty
no
[Music]
mr booker mr booker i
[Music]
mr shelby mr shelby no
mr thune mr thune no mr rubio
mr rubio i
[Music]
mr leahy mr leahy i
mr luhan mr lujan i
foreign
ms ernst ms ernst no
mr romney mr romney
miss cinema miss cinema i
mr brawn mr brawn no
ah
mr warnock mr warnock i
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
mr kennedy mr kennedy no
[Music]
yes
um
[Music]
mr scott mr scott of south carolina
no
[Music]
mr sanders mr sanders i
mr graham mr graham no
mr lankford mr lankford
no mr cornyn mr cornyn
no
[Music]
miss murkowski ms murkowski no
do
ms collins miss collins i
foreign
hey
i
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell no
mr tillis mr tillis no
[Music]
uh
foreign
mr blonde mr blonde no
[Music]
mr king mr king aye
ms klobuchar miss klobuchar i
mr ossoff mr ossoff i
mr hovind mr holven no
my
[Music]
uh
mr merkley mr merkley i
mr cruz mr cruz
no
[Music]
this
mr coons mr coons aye
[Music]
my
mr menendez mr menendez
i miss warren miss warren
[Music]
i
ah
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
do
baby
cool
uh
good
foreign
so
[ __ ]
so
here
foreign
oh
so
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
mr cotton mr cotton no
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
uh
ah
uh
[Music]
come on
um
[Music]
everybody's heard
is there any senator in the chamber who
wishes to vote or
change his or her vote
if not the a's are 52 the nays are 47.
the joint resolution is passed
[Music]
from ohio for the excellent not only
moving this forward but vote counting
that he did
which worked with a little bit of margin
of error
now mr president i move to proceed to
executive session
the question is on the motion all those
in favor say aye
aye opposed no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the motion is agreed to mr president
pursuant to senate resolution 27 the
finance committee being tied on the
question of reporting
i moved to discharge the senate finance
committee from further consideration of
the nomination of chiquita brooks
lassour
of virginia to be administer
administrator of the centers for
medicare and medicaid services
under the provisions of senate
resolution 27 there will be
now up to four hours of debate on the
motion
equally divided between the two leaders
or their designees
with no point of order motions or
amendments
in order for the information of all
senators
we expect to vote on the motion to
discharge to occur around noon tomorrow
wednesday may 12th and i yield the floor
[Music]
senator from ohio is recognized thank my
colleagues for their vote on
on this resolution which was so
important to protect people from
uh being abused by payday lenders this
fall the sj
resolution of 15 resolution sj
resolution 15
will be a big deal saving a lot of money
for a lot of low-income people that have
been fleeced
far too many times i i thank the leader
i thank
in my office laura swanson and john
singelman for their terrific work
and making sure that everybody was here
and everybody was
was um learned these issues this issue
so well and how important that was
for our state and for our country so i i
thank them
mr president i would i ask that by the
following remarks being sort of a
different place in the record
without objection thank you mr president
um each year during police week we honor
the law enforcement officers
who made the ultimate sacrifice and
service to their communities
this year we had the names of four
ohioans to the national law enforcement
memorial who laid down their lives last
year
corporal adam mcmillan of hamilton
county sheriff's office
detective james michael skiernovitz of
cleveland
patrolman anthony hussein dia of toledo
and officer kyle grant of springdale
sadly we already know of two names that
will be added to the memorial next year
officer brandon stalker of the toledo
police department
officer jason lagore who worked for the
ohio department of natural resources
each one of these losses is a tragedy
for a family for a community
and for their fellow officers ms grant's
mother i
i know and i know
talking to her how tragic this is for
her
for her family and for the families of
all of these officers who gave their
lives in service to others
over the past year we've had many
reminders of the work that must be done
to reform and reimagine public safety to
rebuild
trust between law enforcement and
communities
these ohioans lies a reminder of the
ideals
we should strive for officers who are
true public servants
in the best sense of the word people who
gave themselves to their communities
and these ohioans gave so much officer
dia was the father of two
young sons he had married his high
school sweetheart
in a letter he wrote to his family
during ramadan the devout muslim wrote
every day i put on the uniform it's with
the intention to protect the innocent
and the weak
in my community the imam who spoke at
his memorial service said when you think
of islam
think of this man who gave his life on
the fourth of july to defend the values
of the united states
detective james skirnovitz spent serving
my city
in cleveland he served in neighborhood
policing districts in 2013 he joined the
gang impact unit
working to reduce violence in cleveland
he was a devoted father who played
softball for many years traveling to
tournaments
with the steel city enforcers corporal
adam mcmillan
spent 19 years serving the public at the
sheriff's office
in hamilton county cincinnati so many in
his community spoke about his kindness
his pastor said it the memorial service
he was the kind of guy who asked the
person in the drive-through window
how their day was going and his generous
spirit generous spirit will live on
captain mcmillan
was an organ donor and his loss is
giving new life to someone else
kai grant was the reserve officer
training corps
was in the reserve officer training
corps in college after graduating and
working with at-risk kids in cincinnati
she joined the springdale police
department her co-worker said
instead of going into the military and
then going into politics
like many do she wanted to serve the
community
another colleague related story when she
saved a woman's life
the department got a call about a person
considering taking her own life
and they searched and searched but found
no one they were close to giving up
but officer grant didn't she found the
woman in a parking garage in time to
save her life
as part of her dedication to our country
officer grant
interned for a u.s senator while she was
in college that senator's name was joe
biden
earlier this year on his first trip to
ohio as president
joe biden met with officer grant's
mother gina mobley
to thank her for his daughter's service
to him to her country and to her
community
we can't begin to repay the debt we owe
ms mobley and all these families
we can work to reform our systems to
protect more officers and communities
they swear an oath to protect
this week i'm introducing legislation
law enforcement training for mental
health response act
with senator inhofe of oklahoma we've
seen
too many americans both officers and in
in those they serve
hurt or killed when law enforcement
respond to people in their communities
suffering a mental health crisis this
bill would invest in training to help
families resolve those situations
safely for themselves and for the
communities they'd help officers resolve
these situations
safely for themselves and for the
communities they serve
law enforcement officers reformers
advocates all agree we've pushed
too many problems onto the criminal
justice system
expecting officers to be social workers
and crisis responders and family
mediators
without the proper training to fill
those roles we need to actually invest
in mental health and education other
social
support we need to give officers the
training and resources they need to help
when they're called on to respond to
these situations
this police week let's offer many of us
come to the floor to do this but let's
offer
more than empty words let's honor the
memory of these women
and men who laid down their lives and
surface of their community
by getting their fellow officers by
giving by giving their fellow by
by getting their fellow officers the
tools and the training they need
to do their jobs and to build trust with
the communities
they've sworn to protect
in the center from ohio because
the senate proceed to legislative
session and be in a period of mourning
business
the senator's permitted to speak thereon
for up to 10 minutes each
without objection
president if i could say this is kind of
like the old days with you up there
so mr president i ask unanimous consent
the senate proceed to the consideration
of s res
205 submitted earlier today the clerk
will report
senate resolution 205 promoting minority
health awareness and supporting the
goals and ideals of national minority
health month
in april 2021 and so forth
without objection the senate will
proceed
mr president mr president i know no
further debate on the measure
is there further debate hearing none
the question is on adoption of the
resolution
those in favor say aye aye all opposed
no
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it
the president i ask you again resolution
is agreed to mr president asking him
the preamble be agreed to the motions to
reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
without objection uh mr president i ask
unanimous consent the senate proceeded
the consideration of
sres 206 submitted earlier today
the clerk will report senate resolution
206 supporting the designation of
the week of april 18 through april 24
2021
as national crime victims rights weeks
objection the senate will proceed
i asked me to send the resolution be
agreed to the preamble be agreed to the
motions to reconsider
be made and laid up on the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection without objection
president uh last resolution i ask you
has sent that when the senate completes
its business today it adjourn until 10
a.m wednesday
may 12th and following the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings
be approved to date the time for the two
leaders be reserved for the use later in
the day and morning business be closed
further upon the conclusion of morning
business the senate proceed
to executive session to resume
consideration of the motion to discharge
the nomination of
chiquita brooks leshore to be
administrator of the centers for
medicare and medicaid services
from the finance committee that at noon
all time be considered expired the
senator
the senate vote on the motion to
discharge the brooks legion nomination
that the closure motions filed during
yesterday's session the senate ripened
following disposition of the motion
discharge further if the closure is
invoked on executive calendar number 108
ronald strowman all post-cloture time be
considered expired
at 3 30 p.m finally the defending
nominations are confirmed
the motions to reconsider be considered
made and laid up on the table with no
intervening action or debate
and the president be immediately
notified of the senate's action
is there objection without objection
mr president if there's no further
business come before the senate i ask
that it stand adjourned
under the previous order following
remarks as senator inhofe of oklahoma
without objection
mr president the senator from oklahoma
mr president winston churchill
famously said quote there's only one
thing worse than fighting with allies
and that is fighting without them
republicans and democrats agree strong
alliances partnerships are key to
the asymmetric advantage the united
states has over our strategic
competitors like every president before
him
president biden has rightfully made
america's
alliances and partnerships a cornerstone
of his administration
national security policy but alliances
and partnerships
are not a substitute for a strong
american
military a strong military is the
foundation of our
alliances military power creates
leverage and credibility for our
diplomats
and just as importantly it creates it
creates a deterrent
real deterrence cannot be achieved
unless it is
credible and it cannot be credible
unless we properly fund our military
and have our allies and partners with us
it's got to be both
you can't have one or the other and why
because our partnerships are two-way
streets alliances are aren't just for
show
they're not just empty statements that
uh or blindly
uh sending money to support vague goals
these relationships are built on mutual
interests they benefit
us just as much as they benefit our
country just look at the billions of
dollars
some of our allies have contributed to
u.s bases
in their countries national defense
strategy
this this this book is the one we it was
put together
in uh 2018 it was put together by
12 people six republicans
six democrats all experts in their field
in fact one of just this morning was in
a committee hearing
before our committee and this this
document has been
our blueprint for a long period of time
and so this is what we have and this is
what we feel is going to be a
something that will stay with us for a
long time now in this
book it says that and i'm quoting from
it now
mutually beneficial alliances and
partnerships
are crucial to our strategy providing a
durable
asymmetric strategy advantage that no
competitor can rival
or can match but maintaining that
asymmetrical advantage requires much
more than just
simply saying nice things about our
allies and partners
the bipartisan national defense
commission report
written by the the six democrats the six
republicans
make this very clear they say talk about
these alliances and partnerships have
ultimately rested on a foundation of
military strength so when president
biden says america's
alliances are our greatest asset and
then goes
to underfund the military he it just
defies
common sense under underfunding the
military
threatens that very foundation that
other underwrites the
effectiveness of our alliances and
partnerships
let me explain a little bit of how it
works we'll start with the nuclear
modernization
the united states maintains a safe and
effective nuclear arsenal
to protect american families but also to
protect our partners and allies our
nuclear umbrella has three benefits
first
it makes clear to china and russia which
countries
stand with us you know they don't know
otherwise and and they have a terrible
practice of of lying about who what
countries are with us
are or are with them so this makes it
very clear
it's on the dotted line second it has
the benefit of giving those countries
and
the security of relying on our
deterrence
rather than feeling like they have to
develop their own nuclear weapons
and thirdly our umbrella of extended
nuclear deterrence is a pillar of our
goal
of global nuclear non-proliferation
now if we cut back our own nuclear
deterrent
and take away that umbrella which is
what would happen if we reduce our
defense budget
it's likely that nuclear weapons will
become
more common not less president biden has
said
the nuclear proliferation is one of his
priorities
do you see the disconnect here that's
why it's so concerning to me that some
administration officials i'm talking
about the current administration
some of those officials are talking
about
drastically reducing our nuclear
modernization efforts
and i am also concerned that someone in
the administration
and in congress are targeting our fifth
generation stealth
air power and don't get me wrong the
f-35 they've had their problems we all
understand that
but uh it's a cornerstone of our ability
to operate
with our with our allies and our
partners
the f-35 program that's our program
it has 21 allies out there and partners
in it
for many it's their main capability and
will be their primary contribution
to any kind of a high-end problem that
should
come forth now when we talk about
cutting the program
or moving away from it their
government's question our commitment
there's no substitute aircraft or
capability for these
these uh countries we want our allies
and partners to fight along
with us there's no question about that
let's remember what happened
first of all the the f-35 is a fifth
uh generation uh vehicle and we'll
have one other one that was the f-22 i
remember so well just a few years ago
when we were going to have
we're at that time we're going to have
700 f-22
aircraft but we'll only end up with 187
of them
because at the last minute they are
talking like they're talking today
and a lot of people in the
administration saying that we maybe we
don't need
to have as many f-35s but
we absolutely do need to have them we
don't want to make the same mistake now
that we made
uh several years ago with the f-22 our
combatant commanders have already told
us that we'll be
outnumbered in terms of self-fighters in
the western pacific by 2025
and it'll be even worse if uh american
f-22s uh cuts the lead uh
because you know other countries like
our allies in
australia and japan they would be
cutting theirs if we cut
ours but that's just one of the many
serious problems we've got in the
indo-pacific
our partners and allies are worried
about u.s forest posture and our ability
to deter
and if necessary defeat china's use of
military force
i i heard that for myself way back in
2018 when i was in that area in the
south
china sea many of our allies and
partners in that region they they were
clear
they saw firsthand how china was
preparing to swiftly defeat
our forces in the pacific they were
trying to figure out
how if we would be able
there for them when that happened or if
they would be
needing to start cozying up to china you
know that they're going to sit around
and
wait for us to to perform they're going
to have to know that they're
we're going to be there for them and uh
our competition out there in that area
is clearly china
we know what they're doing and we know
what their plans are and uh
we're concerned about it unfortunately
our significant
investment in the military under
president trump was an encouraging sign
to our allies and partners
they're all very proud of us but
after watching the chinese communist
party dismantle democracy in hong kong
and
commit genocide on on the
uh uyghurs in northwest china
our partners and allies in the
indo-pacific are now worried that china
will try to invade and annex taiwan
and how long how many years we've been
talking about that now they are
really concerned about it
general mcmaster testified that taiwan
is and i'm quoting now
the the most significant flash point
that could lead to large-scale
uh scale war saying china would take
military action
against taiwan as soon as as
2020 the former and current commanders
of the indo-pacon both emphasize the
near-term
threat it's a real threat mr president
it's out there
this is a primary reason why the armed
services committee
with overwhelmingly bipartisan support
has put in place our pacific deterrent
initiative we call that the pdi
the pdi is intended to bolster our
degraded force
posture in the indo-pacific to counter
china's military buildup now we gotta
restore the favorable balance of power
in the region where
the problem is the most the most acute
that's west of the international date
line where our partners and allies are
most
immediately threatened by chinese
aggression pdi
is fundamentally about building a
basic infrastructure so that we can
operate with our
allies and partners it will mean more
distributed
and smaller bases maybe hardened
communications as well as
increase in more realistic exercises
with allies and partners
if we if we want pdi to succeed we need
to restore
it properly both admiral davidson and
aki
alino told the armed services committee
that much just last week in the hearing
that we had in our committee
after the hollow promises of the obama
administration to
pivot quote pivot to the pacific
and after almost no change in the u.s
military posture
in the region over the last two decades
our partners
and allies in indo-pacific are worried
and justly so they want to see
sustained investment matching sustained
commitments especially after
president trump's rightfully push them
to step up their own investments uh they
they answer the call but president biden
will create
a credibility problem if we don't
continue to invest at all but so
we want them to do that this is the case
we're going to have to
get this done our endo pacom allies and
partners throughout that region
are watching closely to see what we do
with the defense budget top line
and with the pdi they
what they see is president byron biden's
defense budget that does not even keep
up with inflation now we're talking
about the
defense budget that he came out with
just a couple of weeks ago
and actually had a reduction when it
didn't even meet the inflation at that
time
and uh and it didn't come close to what
was really recommended
by this document that we're supposed to
be using it's a bipartisan document
and so let alone matches the real
growth we need to implement the national
defense strategy so
over in europe biden proclaimed
quote america is back that sounds good
uh
claiming a reversal from the previous
administration it's just not true
but again actions aren't matching words
rhetoric
without resources will devastate our
credibility
and undermine our alliances here
too if defense cuts impact the european
deterrence initiative
it will serve to weaken our european
posture and make our allies and partners
more
susceptible to russian aggression
without a strong
defense budget the biden
administration's bold pledge to support
nato and deter deter russia
will ring hollow for our european allies
and partners
sharing the burden is a key benefit of
our international alliances and
partnerships
but our nato alliances might see the
administration's military reductions
as a signal that they no longer need to
meet their
commitments to spend two percent of the
gdp and i remember when
the previous president and president
trump talked to them about
our allies to start building up and in
participating
nato there are those nations are our
friends
but they're not coming to to the
the the the level that they're going to
have to do to carry their end of it
don't forget
whether we're facing russia china or
other adversaries in another part of the
world
operating jointly with our allies and
partners
is a core part of our ability to deter
conflict in multiple theaters
but it requires investment take the
refueling support we
provided for our french allies in mali
six million pounds of fuel to allow the
french
to take on the critical
counter-terrorism mission and support
their troops on the ground but it would
have cost us
billions to do this mission by ourselves
that's why we need
the allies the same goes in for iraq and
afghanistan somalia yemen and elsewhere
a good portion of our defense budget
pays for
our military to support our allies and
partners so that we don't have to
send our tribs our own troops over there
and our allies can do it for us and it
gives us the insight into
those operations so see what would
happen
if our military's ability to posture
forward and stay ready
is choked by inadequate defense funding
our
allies and partners would suffer not
improve
and the u.s would end up spending more
money for less
security and this goes directly against
the biden
administration's stated goals thinking
that alliances
and partnerships can substitute for
us military capability and
capacity is wishful thinking it's
illogical
black strategy and will harm our
national
security as former defense secretary jim
mattis said
throughout history we see nations with
allies
thrive in nations without allies with
her
if we want to win against our strategic
competitors
it will take both a strong fully
resourced military
as well as strong alliances and
partnerships but let's be clear
one is not an alternative for the other
you got to have
both so it's clear then that we need our
allies so
how do we maintain this mutual
relationship with
robust defense spending three to five
percent real growth
that's what it calls for right here this
year we should have
a three to five percent increase and the
the president's budget has come
actually come out with a net decrease
and that's why this whole thing is so
important just this morning
we had a hearing and we had one of the
authors of this book and i asked them
the same question i said
this was put together back in 2018 is it
still accurate today and said yeah
it is and it doesn't even
increase enough to keep up with
inflation so eric edelman
he's one of the co-sponsors of the uh
of the nds that we're referring to here
that's been our blueprint for
uh for five years now the report said it
best in an article this week
by eric edelman he said in this article
and i'm quoting now it remains a fact
that allies and adversaries will see the
united states commitment
to defense as a crucial bent mark
benchmark
for assessing u.s willingness and
ability to succeed
at long-term competition with its
authoritarian adversaries he continued
this is
eric edelman
quote a tough declaratory policy without
adequate military means
to reinforce it is a recipe for disaster
particularly in the indo-pacific region
so
i would just say this president biden
walks the walk but when it comes to
supporting our allies
they don't do it and and and i and
many others know that it is meaningless
with a strong defense
budget to back it up and we need a
higher
top line we need a higher top line it's
going to have to be somewhere
in the range that is put together by the
group of the
democrats and republicans that outlined
what we have to do
for america to survive and so
we need a higher top line and we're
going to end up getting a higher tie
plan
top line and with that i yield the floor
mr president
until 10 am tomorrow senate stands
adjourned until 10 a.m tomorrow
you